physical systems cannot be conscious
only simulated things can be conscious
consciousness is a virtual property it's
simulated it exists in the dream and the
system that dreams us
according to our best theories right now
is the brain in physics
and the confusion that we have about
this when we think about this arises
through the notion that what we
experience when we look at brains our
brains but we don't these fishy pink
things are elements of our dream that
are generated in non-random fashion in
the parent reality and the parent
reality is something that we can never
have access to we cannot experience
physics there is no way in which the
physical world can be experienced from
inside of a brain
so wouldn't that mean then that there's
no knowledge of the physics possible
then
no that's that's uh what it means uh we
can have knowledge from first principles
which means we can
understand the way in which thinking
could possibly happen which means
understanding the realm of all languages
in the way in which something could mean
something that's one aspect so we have a
priori knowledge which is
a category of ideas that we get by
understanding how systems can
be about other things you can understand
how languages work
and the other thing is that we can
make observations and we can identify
regularities and the observations and
then using our understanding of first
principles to get a notion of what the
significance of these observables is
and so i think it's a good
simplification to say that we find
regular patterns at our systemic
interface and in these regular patterns
we find
non-random ways to disassemble them and
build them into hierarchies of features
and objects